.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, WILL.
RON DESANTIS IS THE GOVERNOR OF
FLORIDA, WATCHING ALL THIS VERY,
VERY INTENSELY.
HE'S DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY IN FLORIDA TONIGHT.
HE JOINS US RIGHT NOW.
GOVERNOR, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
YOU'RE SEEING THE BIGGER PICTURE
HERE.
HOW WOULD YOU ASSESS FLORIDA
RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, TUCKER, THIS IS A
MAJOR, MAJOR STORM.
I MEAN, IT HIT AT 155 MILES AN
HOUR.
THAT IS ONE TICK BELOW A
CATEGORY 5.
UNLIKE CATEGORY 5 STORMS WE'VE
HAD, THIS IS A HUGE STORM IN
TERMS OF ITS SIZE.
IT BROUGHT RECORD STORM SURGE IN
COLLIER, LEE COUNTIES, AND IT'S
CONTINUING TO CHURN THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
SO, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE GOING TO
END UP WITH MANY MORE PEOPLE
WITHOUT POWER.
OBVIOUSLY IN SOUTHWEST FLORIDA,
AS SOON AS THE STORM PASSES, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THE STATE HAS MARSHALED HUNDREDS
OF AIRCRAFT, HIGH WATER
VEHICLES, THE CAPACITY TO GO BY
LAND, AIR, OR BY SEA TO HELP
PEOPLE.
THEY WILL DO THAT.
THAT WILL NEED TO TAKE PLACE.
THEN YOU'LL HAVE A MAJORREST TO
RESTORE POWER.
WE HAVE 100 CELL TOWERS WE CAN
HELP STAND UP TO HELP DO
COMMUNICATIONS.
WE HAVE OVER 42,000 LINEMEN AND
OTHER PERSONNEL ASSOCIATED WITH
RESTORING POWER.
IF YOU'RE DRIVING ANYWHERE IN
FLORIDA, I-10, I-95, YOU SEE
THESE TRUCKS COMING INTO THE
STATE, AND IT'S BEEN ONGOING, SO
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE BIGGEST
PROBABLY LOGISTICAL EFFORT IN
THE HISTORY OF THE STATE.
AS SOON AS IT'S SAFE TO GO IN,
THEY'LL GO IN, TRY TO RESCUE
PEOPLE FIRST.
THEN TRY TO STABILIZE THE
SITUATION, RESTORE POWER, GET
FUEL IN THERE, AND MAKE SURE
PEOPLE CAN COMMUNICATE.
>> Tucker: THE STORM CAME ASHORE
IN SOUTHWEST FLORIDA, LEE,
CHARLOTTE COUNTIES IN THERE.
IT'S HARD TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING ON THERE.
YOU WOULD KNOW.
HOW BAD DOES IT LOOK, THE
DAMAGE, DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S CLEARLY
THE BIGGEST FLOOD EVENT WE'VE
EVER SEEN IN THAT PART OF THE
STATE.
I MEAN, THAT'S NOT JUST LEE AND
CHARLOTTE.
THAT WOULD BE COLLIER.
MASSIVE, MASSIVE STORM SURGE.
YOU HAVE PLACES IN THOSE
COUNTIES THAT HAVE MASSIVE
STANDING WATER.
THAT, OF COURSE, PRESENTS A LOT
OF HAZARDS ON THE BACK END.
WE'VE BEEN TELLING FOLKS, BE
CAREFUL ONCE THE STORM GOES
PAST.
YOU KNOW, IN HURRICANE IRMA, I
HAD FOLKS PULL THE NUMBERS,
SEVEN DEATHS DIRECTLY CAUSED BY
HURRICANE IRMA.
77 DEATHS CAUSED IN THE
AFTERMATH FOR DOWNED POWERLINES
OR MISUSING GENERATORS.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A MAJOR
DISASTER.
IN TERMS OF THE STRUCTURAL
DAMAGE, I THINK IT'S TOO SOON.
WE'RE GETTING INTERMITTENT
REPORTS, BUT IT'S REALLY GOING
TO HAVE TO PASS.
WE'LL HAVE PEOPLE OUT THERE AT
THE LOCAL AND STATE LEVEL
ASSESSING THE DAMAGE.
BUT MY SENSE IS, I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
FLOOD EVENTS WE'VE EVER HAD.
WHAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN, HOW
MUCH DAMAGE THE WIND DID.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S VERY SIGNIFICANT.
AS YOU KNOW, TUCKER, IN THAT
PART OF FLORIDA, YOU KNOW A LOT
OF THOSE BUILDINGS THAT ARE
BUILT ARE BUILT SPECIFICALLY TO
WITHSTAND A CATEGORY 5
HURRICANE.
SO WE'LL SEE FLORIDA BUILDING
CODES, HOW DID THEY HOLD UP?
HOPEFULLY THEY HELD UP OKAY.
>> Tucker: WHEN A NATURAL
DISASTER LIKE THIS STRIKES THE
STATE, IT IS COMMON, I THINK
IT'S ALWAYS THE CASE, THAT THE
STATE RECEIVES FEDERAL AID.
GIVEN HOW POLITICIZED THINGS ARE
AT THE MOMENT, ARE YOU CONFIDENT
YOU'RE GOING TO GET THE FEDERAL
SUPPORT FLORIDA NEEDS?
>> SO I ACTUALLY SPOKE WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
HE SAID HE WANTS TO BE HELPFUL.
SO WE DID SUBMIT A REQUEST FOR
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE NEXT 60
DAYS AT 100%.
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT.
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT STORM.
SO WE HAVEN'T HEARD BACK FROM
IT.
I'M ACTUALLY CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE DO.
AS YOU SAID, TUCKER, WE LIVE IN
A POLITICIZED TIME, BUT WHEN
PEOPLE ARE FIGHTING FOR THEIR
LIVES, WHEN THEIR LIVELIHOOD IS
AT STAKE, LOST EVERYTHING, IF
YOU CAN'T PUT POLITICS ASIDE FOR
THAT, YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO.
I'LL WORK WITH ANYBO